this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happened you bad
[__] it's Monday December the
19th Maryland sports fans listen up
DraftKings sports book is now live in
your [__] State go to Jimmy's
Crab Corner get a crab cake download
DraftKings and let's get this
[__] party started Jack we got
a lot to talk about when I drove down on
the NBA action it's got to be with
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting part of the NBA new customers
bet five dollars on pre-grain money line
any NBA team win that game you get 150
in three bets plus everyone can combine
multiple bets for bigger payout with
DraftKings same game ballets who to
watch let me tell you something you got
to be looking at Memphis you got to be
looking at
Golden State you got to be looking at
Milwaukee there's a lot of great NBA
teams as far as tonight's concerned we
got Green Bay given seven points to the
Rams great [__] game don't forget to
look at the prop bets on this that's
what draftking shines so download the
app now take it in on Hollywood Holiday
hoop action
sign up with code Joey plays five dollar
pregame moneyline bet on any NBA team to
win and you're gonna get 150 in free
bets when they do only at DraftKings
Sportsbook
with code Joey so do me a favor download
the DraftKings app but better yet also
download the DraftKings fantasy app
they've got tremendous [__] deals and
pools every day but it starts with you
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
enter code Joey and let's get this
[__] party started minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply see
show notes for details let's do this
[__] download the app like that
candle Mike let's get this party started
it's [__] Monday
[Music]
foreign
[__] it's uh the pre-Christmas
[__] week I hope you
[__] are all excited about
what's going on Sam is coming the whole
thing everybody's jumping up and down
but it's [__] Monday [__] and
there's nobody better than you that's it
that's how we start this podcast off in
case you're feeling a little low right
now today people you know this is the
type of week people like I don't have
enough money I can't buy my grandmother
a present yes listen guys it works out I
told you a thousand times it's not about
the [__] presence and what you show
up with it's just showing up sometimes
with a handshake in your heart and
that's it just listen man some
Christmases are better than others other
people walking around wounded because
the family passing you know what put
them in the back burner you know say a
prayer for them light a candle try to
have the best [__] holiday you could
have that's it that's guys it's it's
simple you can sit around around and be
a [__] mope
over the holidays or some people hate
the [__] holidays I used to be one of
those people but things happen things
change you meet people you meet friends
you got a family and all sudden
Christmas means something completely
different and you're out of the goddamn
wood so don't let it get you down it's
just another [__] day and Hey
listen I was down for about 20 [__]
Christmases I was down for about 30
Christmases I sat there I don't have
money for presents I don't have money
for Coke I don't have money yeah I don't
have a Christmas present for my coke
dealer what the [__] you know what am I
gonna do but at the end of the game did
it [__] matter it doesn't [__]
matter so
worry about your health worry about your
family and just say next year
listen I owe you next year and listen if
you need to sleep all Christmas day
that's great too man if it works for you
just try to have one you know if you can
find one [__] positive thing like
maybe somebody's gonna make a turkey or
something like that you like turkey I
don't know
but I I remember like a Thanksgiving I
had that I had nobody around no car
no [__] money I had enough money for
a Boston Market turkey
I had like two joints
I had like a bottle of beer or something
and a thing of soda
and I'll never forget like that morning
I started up really down on myself like
what the [__] man
by the afternoon I got my white meat I
got my mashed potatoes you dope them up
with a little stick of butter and [__]
and the Thanksgiving wasn't that bad it
was just a solo Thanksgiving and you
just fine listen I got two joints on
Christmas could be worse I could be in
the county jail with no joints eating a
[__] dead salami sandwich so and
trust me I've been there too it's not
[__] fun and that's what you focus on
for me this year listen I'm happy I
don't have any gigs this week like I
have to run around and [__] I got enough
[__] to do just walking into a store
I have such a hard time just walking
into a store guys
I know a lot of you guys like but Joey
in it no no
I tried last week I went to CVS to try
to get some [__] uh
that that's how my Christmas shopping
start I went to CVS to try to get
Christmas cards and there was nothing
there was like nothing I got like one
card from my daughter everybody else had
bogus [__] cards so I got a little
down you know when you go to the first
stop and they got nothing for you you're
like Jesus Christ I usually go to like
four stores tops
and I go in and out I know exactly what
I want to [__] get I got a couple
gifts left I gotta go run this week but
I'm not killing myself I've like I said
two weekends in a row
Uncle Joey as Keen as I say I am I've
said let me go out
on a [__] Saturday and see what I can
find
yesterday
there was a line there was a right turn
I had to make
there was a line in that right turn
that I would have been that line no no
[__] lie I would have been in that
line for 25 minutes
just waiting to make a right if I would
have committed to that road I saw where
the line was so I kept going I'm like
I'm [__] dead today and then there
was a line by my Costco on route 9.
that [__] LED all the way up to
Mars between people getting I don't know
what all these people getting gas where
the [__] are you going there was a line
just to get gas that was you know
and then Route 18 North
they were sticking out like the cars
were out
and I looked and I saw [__] red
lights all the way up and I go well I
guess I'm not going to the mall because
I was going to go to New Brunswick mall
maybe East Brunswick
see what they had there go to Barnes and
Nobles I like the little Barnes and
Nobles and [__] uh
whatever that [__] them all is New
Brunswick and I was gonna go man I go up
that that was my shopping so I went to a
health food store and I'm like maybe
I'll buy some people health food
products and [__] so I ordered some
honest stuff for people and uh that's it
that's you know you do the best you can
guys you do the best you can some people
love to go Christmas shopping they
really do
there's some people that started
Christmas shopping in September that's
what they do there's some people who
love to go to [__] weddings there's a
friend of mine I talk to all the time I
ask her about the kids they're at a
wedding how many [__] people do they
know that's getting married I mean what
the [__] everything she went to a
marriage went to a wedding my Saturday
the 17th of December who the [__] gets
married on the 17th of December like do
you need the tax break I mean who the
[__] gets married on that day
so you know me I'm not a shopper guys I
go in I even hate to try on clothes
like before I go clothes shopping I'll
go upstairs and see what size my Levi's
are and then I'll run right in there and
get that same [__] size that's how
lazy I am I don't try them on I just
want to be in and out guys I I was never
a shopper that's why I don't have
anything I I can't I don't I don't know
I [__] hate going into places
especially this time of the year you
ever go into a place with money and
nobody takes care of you you were going
to a place you're like all right I got
my 500 limit down on the Visa [__]
Express card you know whatever the [__]
you know when you have those first
little limits and you get it up to like
420 and then you work it down to like 50
and you're like all right I'm gonna have
to buy a shirt for Saturday night
remember we used to buy a shirt for
Saturday night like I haven't bought a
shirt for Saturday night in 30 [__]
years remember that when you're like I
want to go buy a shirt for Saturday and
I'm going to a club and [__] I haven't
bought a shirt I don't give a [__] about
a shirt for Saturday night over 30
goddamn years I just remembered that I
that was when my hatred came a [__]
see it comes out when you talk therapy
pays [__] sucking just talking about
[__] that was where it came from
I I don't know but anyway the holiday
seasons is here and you're gonna make
the best of them I'm gonna make guys I'm
looking forward to the holidays this
year I'm looking forward to the show on
the 28th
I'm looking forward to putting something
together for New Year's I don't know
what like I just want to put something
together for New Year's I went to eat
with one of my Jujitsu teachers at this
restaurant we've been talking the guy
was like if you want to stop in and do
10 minutes on New Year's Eve because we
have a DJ I'm like I can't just stop it
and do com the other but not nothing
like that I just want to do something
like you know I don't know
I'm not gonna drink I'm not gonna drive
yeah have some fun maybe do a block
party with the snow
I don't know but anyway this week we're
going to talk about resolutions because
the [__] the time is coming and
something happened this weekend I didn't
know exactly what had happened
I just saw some stuff on Saturday and
then I saw some stuff
yesterday and I saw some stuff this
morning but last night I read a few
emails from people going what do I think
about Tom Segura going off on his
podcast did you see that Mike uh
Thompson girl went off on his podcast
about people I don't know well
it's not even jealousy you know and
it's about
insecurity
it's a very big insecurity and I add
that insecurity for years
and that's what made me a thief and in
turn
it made me hate certain people
you know when people have things you
don't have
it makes you look at them a certain way
either you look at them with
you know every I don't even know what
the word is either you look at them and
you're proud for them maybe happy
oh you look at them and you say why does
that guy have that and I don't have that
you know Tom did a video there was a
segment of his uh two bears one cave
where he's like whenever he hits a watch
or a car
people reach out to him and say you make
me feel bad or whatever jealousy or
whatever he was talking about and he
made some great points he made a point
that uh he talked about your mental
state like wait you know what your
mental state is and he's that dog a lot
of people gonna find that like the
people the two people reached out to me
actually reached out to me for me to
like
insert a negative comment I had a look
at it and think about it before I even
brought it here because
it's the thing that we all have
when I was a [__] kid I [__] hated
most people who had [__] I didn't have
I hated most people that had parents
that were successful and were able to
pass on things to their children you
always looked at those kids as weak or
whatever but it's not that it's a
jealousy that you have you say they're
going to be weak or they're spoiled you
know the [__] that they give you
guys it doesn't [__] matter what
matters is you and how you do it you
know I talked about venary the other day
on the podcast my dear friend that owns
the funeral Paul and we were kids with
venaries and as I got older I got with
Anthony
you know how many nights they went out
to a restaurant or bar
and got a steak and a couple beers and
I didn't have the 20 hours to get a
[__] steak or the thirty dollars to
get a steak I don't have the money to
get a beer in fact all my friends did
that and as I got older yes I got little
jobs bartending jobs whatever but when I
would go on those things one dinner and
my check for the week would be over with
a dinner a gram of coke and a few
cocktails you [__] done
you're done so the rest of the nights
when you go out with them and they're
doing things you can't afford to do yes
this insecurity yes you feel [__]
shitty yes like you're like [__] that
dude he could have bought me a gram of
coke to you no
aren't in business to buy you [__] and
people aren't in business to worry about
your feelings always remember that
you know
when I moved
to New Jersey
towards the end of the church
it was very overwhelming it was very
overwhelming and we'll pick it back I'll
tell you what I real when it really
started in my life
I got away from that like listen the
mindset that Tom is talking about is
that one day you go you know what
you know I don't have that so instead of
hating the [__] person or hating his
parents or whatever you hate on go guess
what I'm gonna make a mental note that's
what I want
he's said you were thinking like a loser
yes that's what I want
that's what I want and I gotta figure
out a way to get it you know when I was
a kid somebody said to me what do you
want in your life what's your biggest
goal and I was like I wanted you know
when I was gonna Coke and [__] I wanna
uh Testarossa one of those [__] uh
cars with the wings and [__] and the
guy's like cut it out and put it on your
wall look at it every day you know what
that did for me nothing
that made me even more out of touch
because what I needed to put on the wall
was to picture the Testarossa and how I
was gonna attain it what steps I needed
to do to attain it you got to stand more
you can't eat out every night you know
you got to go to work 80 hours a week
even to the littlest [__] note like
you know how am I gonna attain this
[__] 300 000 car at least that's what
it was when I was looking at it
you know so again when I used to hang
out with the you know Colorado I met
guys that were well you know I made
[__] an hourly wage I was a mother I
had no high school diploma but you don't
have no high school diploma but then you
want somebody to give you a [__] and
thirty thousand dollar car it don't work
that way I wish it did we all wished it
did right but it don't work that way so
when I would be in those Boulder when I
moved to Boulder you know me [__]
kids I hung out with in Boulder
that I would go to lunch with them and
they'd have a [__] Audi and they were
three years younger than me and I'm like
uh-ha I gotta ride my bike to meet you
for lunch and meanwhile they have a
[__] Audi and whatever that co-signed
it but they still had to make the
[__] payments on it so before you go
raising your head you know how bad that
makes you feel because I tell you
there's nothing worse to me there's no
worse feeling than being in your 20s
if you can make it out of your [__]
20s to your 30 I swear to God if you can
make it out of your 20 to your 30 you're
going to go a long way most people don't
even make it Amy Winehouse didn't make
it Jimi Hendrix didn't make it out this
[__] place a lot of [__]
that were coming out of the gate that
successful didn't make it it's a lot
it's a lot of [__] pressure to put on
someone I'm not saying nothing negative
I'm just saying like it's tough to make
it out of your 30s
20s it's [__] tough I used to have a
bit the one that I was just sitting
there I was talking to somebody and they
were like I don't know what to do I'm 28
this had to be two years ago in L.A
years ago and from the conversation I
wrote a bit because I'm like you know
in your 20s it's a [__] world and I
didn't write the bit like at home that
night as I was telling talking advice
back and forth
I'm like hey man you know
being in your 20s sucks
it sucks for more reason than one you
get beat up
you get abused you got nothing you
[__] get dumped by girls you think
that if you have a car girls are gonna
[__] you that's not gonna happen either
you can have a [__] Magic Carpet if
you're ugly you're [__] ugly if he
got no personality you got no
personality that's me all right I don't
give a [__] if you got a magic carpet
with a [__] Indian guy in the [__]
way it's not gonna work out for you so
but that's the [__] we think in our
[__] 20s it's the dumbest thing I got
listen I go for hours about the stupid
[__] I did in my 20s and what I thought
and what I expected and how I thought it
was going to just get
given to me like I really thought it was
gonna get
given to me I'm not lying to you guys
and then when it wasn't given to me I
started taking it
I started taking it
you don't think that was a problem that
that's a fuel that was an insecurity
that I had growing up
and then I got to LA and then used
getting cars with Comics you know here
you just did a seven minute open mic and
you get in a comic's car
who's got [__] bat wings and machine
gun turrets and you know and you're like
oh Someday I'm gonna have this how do
you think I felt when I moved to LA and
my best friend was Doug stanhoe and he
had the World by the balls and that was
one of his funkies I'd walk into a place
where and people go
who's this [__] guy
what do you think the insecurity you
build then
and then you're like you know what
Stanhope is my brother he's my main man
I don't want nothing from him
I just want him to show me the ropes now
I gotta go get my own ropes I could have
sat with Stan over you ever see like a
comic or a musician or somebody famous
and he's always got eight guys with him
the same eight guys yeah some of them
are there to help him and they really
care for them for those guys are there
to see what the [__] they can get you
know so those are all you know [__] that
happens to you when you're young then I
moved to LA and and like I said you know
you have all these you're around you're
in a room with Chris Rock how do you
think I felt the first time Chris Rock
was in a room and I'm at The Comedy
Store
he's got something he's got what I want
he's got what I want
so do I [__] hate him do I kiss his
ass no I watch his set I watch what he's
doing that I'm not doing and I pay
attention to him oh he's in L.A for two
weeks working on his [__] Oscar set
well let me [__] uh follow all his
sets and see what he does differently
than I'm not doing that's completely
different than me sitting there hating
and then there's another flip side to
that in L.A
and then you know you get into The
Comedy Store and there's a bunch of guys
I was talking to somebody the other day
and they were telling me they're
focusing on something their big Focus
was uh
this thing and and
they were trying to expand their
business
and
uh thank you brother they were trying to
expand their business and
they did it but the business wasn't
working
it just wasn't working out that time you
know
so I had to close it up and I said to
him
your business in this field is so high
like it's great now you're D it's like
okay let me give you an example it's
like having a jiu jitsu School
in a small Market
being the first Brazilian in [__] in
Indiana
okay and opening up a store
uh could Jiu-Jitsu school in downtown
Indianapolis
there was maybe another martial arts
store maybe there was a jiu jitsu place
and since you're Brazilian you Blossom
you have a great kids program you
Blossom you're doing better than you
ever [__] thought you're doing you
would you anticipated a hundred students
you got a hundred kids and 300 [__]
students and they're there every [__]
night and you gotta hire uh you know
other instructors and strengthen Fitness
guys you want to make this the complete
jiu jitsu martial arts [__] place but
then one day you gotta wild bug up your
ass you say you know what I met a girl
in [__] New Jersey
so I'm going to move up to New Jersey
and open up a school up there now you
come up here and you got the Gracies you
got Garden State you got [__] you
know you got a lot of you got the Silver
Fox you got all these great Jiu Jitsu
schools Gracie godwood Gracie Long
Branch and you want to plant your flag
in the middle of this
and it's a little slow for you so you
start hiring marketing firms and blah
blah blah and this guy and this guy and
influences and you just dumped a hundred
thousand dollars and
it's not working
you you didn't fail you just made a bad
decision you took your game into a
market
that you were going to struggle in
it was oversaturated now you're going to
go up there why did you even do that I
understand you had a a thing there was
other ways to do it but listen we
learned from our failures so who gives a
[__] now you go back and but he still
has that school in Kentucky
that is blossoming so he has lost
nothing he tried he failed and he's lost
nothing but it is frustrating
but you have to think about what you got
you know how many times at The Comedy
Store
I mean guys it got to the point where it
was embarrassing
how many Comics would say come up and
you know I knew them from the road you
know when I got to the store 97 98 99
2000 I was meeting feature acts I'm a
[__] I was a medium mediocre feature
Act
and I would meet other feature acts that
I met on the road and they'd come in and
go you're getting the spot do you have a
spot tonight I'm like yeah [__] 12
45. I wish I had a [__] spot you know
I wonder who's asked you had a kiss I
wonder if you had to sleep with Mitzi
and all those little remarks they weigh
on you I know he was goofing around but
no he's not that's the [__] people say
when they got three or four cocktails in
them and the truth is coming out of them
you know who you're up to sleep with you
had to eat Missy's [__] or whatever the
[__] stupid [__] they say you know is
the talent coordinator gay did you sleep
but there's always a [__] excuse and
these guys will be up there every
[__] night complaining complaining
and then they would be that I forget
what the list was
then they got put on there was so I'm
dealing with a handful of those guys I'm
also dealing with a handful of people
that have been put on Missy passed them
but then they did something and Misty
stopped Mitzi stopped giving them sets
so now they go up and they put
themselves on the Fallout list oh my God
and that so now I'm dealing with the
guys that don't get spots because
they're not regulars that's one thing
and now I'm dealing with the guys that
are regulars but aren't getting spots
and they're [__] putting the whammy
on me so now you're feeling guilty
for not
you know I gotta feel guilty yeah for
having a [__] spot for doing my job
that's what I guess what Tom is trying
to say like in in [__] short form
like you're mad at Tom yeah
do you know the amount of weekends that
Tom is working
built Burke Reicher
Kevin Hart
there's guys
that I look at
and I have the utmost respect for them
and I say to myself I can never do that
I can never do what Kevin Hart's doing
even if you put me in arenas magically
overnight
did the work output that Kevin Hart puts
out is
it's it's uh
you I [__] don't know what to say
you know instead of Kevin Hart crying
instead of Kevin Hart Kevin Hart could
talk a lot of [__] black lives matter a
lot no he's going to be a [__]
billionaire
I don't know if you've seen any of his
interviews Kevin Hart knows exactly what
the [__] he wants to do he wants to be a
[__] billionaire
Tom Segura like the first black
millionaire or something like that he
wants to own a team he knows what the
[__] he wants to do nobody gave him [__]
nobody gave him [__] when I see [__]
Kevin Hart driving a [__] helicopter
do you think I sit there and go oh you
know Kevin no I'm like that [__]
works hard number two Tom Segura go look
at this anywhere tour he's going to Mars
that motherfucker's doing Mars Saturn
Venus he's doing something with Elon
Musk he's going everywhere
yes he makes great money but nobody's
giving it to him guys he's earning it
but Chrysler he's going to die I love
bird he's gonna drink that dados until
he [__] you know
he's out there he earns every dollar he
could get
why are you jealous of all these guys
for what they're doing all these guys I
give him Tom Papa Works constantly
[__] two kids just like me one kid
and I complain about having one [__]
kid
so you know these guys earned their
[__] keep I'll never forget
one of the worst feelings of my life and
I'll tell you guys what it was
one of the best things that ever
happened to me was getting the longest
yard you know it was a Dream movie for
me I I liked Reynolds I liked Adam
Sandler you know I wanted to get the
movie I shot the movie
the movie did great in the box office I
was very proud of myself people I did
great for being a [__] criminal
stand-up comic
tweet about six months after the movie
came up
I had eight
I had [__] Adam Sandler showing me a
letter
to the comedian
had written him
telling him that I wasn't really Italian
I want you to think about that guys
telling Adam Sandler when you hired him
for big Tony did you know his name is I
don't even know what my name is in the
movie you have to look up when I have
the Anthony Graziano or somebody
guys that's what they wrote
the first [__] paragraph was about me
not being Italian
how bad of a day are you having did you
not see the James Khan was Jewish he was
The Godfather Andy Garcia was Cuban he
was The Godfather [__] nine whatever
the [__] disaster was you know what do
you think everybody's [__] really
Chinese or anything you know but that
was his opening
now I knew who the comic was I didn't
call him up at home and [__] Adam
called me into the office like look at
read this [__]
and I'm like wow this is you know and it
hurts for about two minutes I'm not
gonna tell you it doesn't hurt you you
shed stages with this person you've shed
rides with him you've had discussions
with them
and this is the letter
you write the Adam [__] Sandler
hold on one second and now for Words my
[__] sponsors better out
what's happening you Savages this
episode is sponsored by better help
listen if life came with a user manual
things wouldn't be easy for everybody
but it doesn't so when it's not working
for you it's normal to feel stuck I felt
stuck for years that's why I chose
betterhelp.com listen therapy is
important I always looked at therapy as
ah but once I got in it and I saw the
advantages I feel great now therapists
are trained to help you learn productive
coping skills and that's what I needed
to learn how to cope with a lot of stuff
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and chat therapy
sessions you can choose not to see
anybody on camera or you could see
everybody
as the world's largest therapy service
Better Health has matched 3 million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists available 100 online
plus it's affordable plus we'll hook you
up with a therapist within three days
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
match with a therapist and if things
aren't click clicking we could switch
you over to a new therapist it's that
easy it shouldn't be simple no waiting
rooms no traffic no endless searching
for the right therapist better help is
the way to go learn more and save 10
percent on your first month
and betterhelp.com when you enter code
Diaz Diaz again I'm going to give you
the 10 off your first month better help
is Affordable you'll have a therapist
quicker than of in-person therapist and
it works so do me a favor better help
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com slash Joey thank
you for visiting the joint and thank you
for using better help we're back so yeah
this [__] writes a letter
to Adam Sandler and then the second part
of it was I don't know if you know this
Mr Sandler but Joey Coco Diaz is a
well-known drug dealer and he also went
to prison
what's that got to do
when you look at it yes I made a mistake
you know I sold drugs I had a good time
I didn't deny it but at the same time
what's that got to do I auditioned
like everybody else for this [__]
movie it wasn't given to me nobody
picked my name out of a [__] hat yeah
I auditioned for this fair and [__]
square
and I think he auditioned for it that
was his anger that he had auditioned for
this role and he you know that wasn't
even it
then people were like hey you know it's
lucky for you to say you were an Adam
Sandler movie
then you know remember Adam Sandler came
out in 2005. I quit doing coke in 2007.
I always remember hitting like kind of a
mental Rock Bottom when I had to do
heroin and [__] I'm not a whiner but I'm
going to tell you part of my [__]
pain those days was feeling bad that I
had done well
I had a dear dear dear friend of mine at
the time who was one of my first friends
when I moved to LA
pulled me aside one day and just
call me out for a thousand things that I
had done that at the end of the day
didn't matter today we're best friends
we don't even discuss it anymore
but she called me out for like well that
time you had to Gig you didn't give it
to me like oh [__] that it was like
and I'm like think about what you're
saying
you're saying that
when they called me for [__] The
Longest Yard of Spider-Man 2 I should
have gave him your name
like it was [__] like that you don't
know how many times I've walked into an
audition and have told the cast and
director listen I'm happy that you
called me in here I'm very proud that
you called me in here but before
anything I'm not right for this role
this is a role for Rudy Moreno this is a
role for Willie bar Center this is a
role for I've done that a thousand times
because I used to go to a thousand
auditions for [__] Mexican rolls and
I'd walk in there and go listen and
they'd even go oh what the [__] and I go
I know the guy you're looking for is
Guzman or Rudy Moreno I gave Rudy
Miranda like through Rose you know but
from just going in there it doesn't
matter what I'm trying to say is that
people would call me up and like [__]
you know well how did you get the Adam
Sandler movie how come I can't be in
that I'm saying the movie and it hurt my
[__] feelings these people are my
friends I [__] do comedy with them or
whatever so I had to change my mind you
know at that time I was like [__] it I
can't talk to these people no more
they're not going to go out of their way
to bring me the [__] down
on this podcast on the joint and the
church and Beauty and the Beast
I never discuss money
I don't discuss elaborate vacations well
maybe because I don't go on them
you know I don't discuss millionaire
type [__] because I'm not a [__]
millionaire there's a ton of
millionaires out there I worked hard for
a few years my wife put some money away
because she's an accountant we got the
house we got the cars we lease like
everybody else we make [__] monthly
payments like everybody else
you know do I have a [__] security
for my uh retirement yeah I got a
stacked pension I got [__] Social
Security if it you know the Russians
don't think that I got a lot of [__]
that you know it's not I might not
[__] happen I got my wife got me a an
annuity plan whatever the [__] you call
them a 401k whatever the [__] like
everybody else has but
that didn't give me the right to buy a
[__] Maserati I think the reason why
I acted like I did was because I
remember how I felt when people spoke
about [__] even a simple thing like
listen when I go the only thing I ever
put on Instagram or whatever is when I
go eat a nice dinner I want you guys to
know it's a great [__] place and I'll
take pictures of King's Chinese
restaurant I take pictures of [__]
you know any place really yeah sometimes
you go to cousins sometimes you go to
Osteria when Lee comes to town and we'll
get the shrimp and [__] like that but if
you guys know this that's my only I
drive a Subaru
we're very modest in this home I'm not
looking to uh compete with the Joneses
I've never been in business to compete
with the Joneses that'll [__] take
you down quicker than anything that's a
[__] insecurity thing too well I
gotta run with her my sister's married
uh you know women do it all the time
their sisters my husband has this now
they go into a [__] War the wife is
talking to husband all that [__] is
[__] insecurity man and it
it just [__] with your head it doesn't
take you anywhere
the mindset Tom was talking about was
really looking at your life and going
what do I need to do to have that you
know if if there was a few podcasts in
the beginning when Joe was doing those
uh
the ones from his home when I went off
on Susquehanna and
the one uh when I went off about
the girl giving blow jobs at The Comedy
Store you know all those days of
podcasting I once got an email from
somebody and they were like Joey we like
you we think you're funny but you're
anger you know climbs over
2009 I had a certain anger going to me
it wasn't an anger woe was me
it wasn't that anger at all it wasn't an
anger that
nobody never gives me nothing it was an
anger of
reality and in a way it sounded negative
how I came across with it but it was
very positive
you know my wife and I were talking
about last week about a lot of guys that
are my age that lived in La that had
shitty apartments and that had given
their whole life to this career
got a little bit of success but now at
this age now that we're in trouble you
know now you're you don't have any
children no grandchildren no money put
away no wife no nothing you know you
gave your whole life for this
I gave my life a comedy but I would have
never let that happen for me I never
wanted to end up I
I made a lot of sacrifices and
everything but I didn't want
to dedicate everything I don't even know
how to say this
I didn't want to end up like what you
know being a 60 year old comic in La
still doing open mics still telling
people Mitzi saw me one time and she
owed me almost made me a regular you
know I don't want to be one of those
guys I never want to be one of those
guys so to not be one of those people
your mindset has to change
and it's like what do I need to do to
have this [__]
I was angry I was never angry at Joe
Rogan I knew how hard he worked and he
had taught me I learned that that was
the ethic you know when I first met Joe
[__] if somebody was paying me 25 Grand
to shoot an episode on TV and I had a
spot at the store for 15 dollars
I'm not going to a [__] store you
know I'm not going to work all day to go
to the store Joe is the opposite
Joe would go to the store for that 15 so
I understood the level of commitment
that was needed right from Joe right
right from hanging out with him in the
beginning like you do that
like if I went to a TV shooting all day
and I knew they were going to give me 28
000 25
000. I'm getting in my car I'm going to
drug dealer's house I am not going to
waste my time and go to some [__]
comedy store and try to be a [__]
comedian that's not gonna happen but Joe
did
so when you look at Joe for all the
things he has
you know when Joe wanted to be a host of
the UFC he didn't put an application in
and fight no he called Dana
storm hey can I come be a host for free
or whatever the [__] you call I'm a host
but a commentator and the first six
months he probably did it for free he
paid his own plane ticket on Friday
night and he'd go to Vegas in the
daytime work out and then go to those
[__] fights at night and call him
when I first met him that's what he'd do
I'd ask him when he'd be at the store
tomorrow night no I gotta go to Vegas
for UFC you want to come uh no I didn't
know what the USC was I didn't you know
but that's the mindset
that's the mindset
so when 2009 I had the mindset that you
know what I didn't get nowhere
my wife is going to marry me I'm very
lucky I want to have a new life I kind
of went away from uh comedy and then we
were doing podcasts and Joe talked me
into doing a podcast
from how well I was doing on his he's
like dog you got to start a podcast you
got to start a podcast and I always knew
if I got a chance to tell my story it
would have even not the playing field
with comedy
guys look don't believe the hype I'm a
good comic I can make people laugh but
I'm not a great great comic there's a
lot of great great [__] Comics out
there I was on my way I was working very
hard
that was the inspiration I had from
losing that shitty mindset
that Tom's talking about and Bert we're
talking about to committing to a higher
mindset
like I still remember in 2000
11 you know
I was getting all these hundred dollar a
day movies
my phone was ringing well my phone was
ringing with them
and Something Happened One Night I was
watching something and one of my movies
was on like an old movie I had done or
something
oh it was one of those holiday movies
with Dean Kane which will be on this
week but I'm gonna get paid for them I
don't get residuals on those The
Producers [__] uh flip the country
they moved down to the same place with a
guy from FTX was I don't know if smart
so I'll never forget going I'm work
doing all these [__] movies even the
the dog holiday Disney movies were 100
miles a day
I hope you guys know that
first one I did with Dean Kane was a
hundred dollars a day and I did it watch
that one the dog that saved Christmas I
[__] rocked him that one for 100 a
day and they came back on me for 100 a
day but a little bit of the back end
and I started rocking on those but to
make a long story short
I got the [__] I was getting all
these hundred dollar day movies and then
this guy called me up to do a [__]
100 day series
I'm like what he's like yeah it's a
mafia family that lives in a [__]
Funeral Parlor and guys I needed the
money I need the insurance so I was
ready to do it I said
I was watching TV and there's that
[__] thing with Dean Kane Dean Kane
who played [__] Superman Dean Kane
who spent his life in this his father
was a [__] director his stepfather
Dean Kane knows a lot about shooting
[__] movies and stuff and acting and
whatnot and here I am doing these things
with Dean Kane I'm getting laughs and
whatever I looked at it and I go [__]
that thing for 100 hours
next morning I woke up and I went
against anything I believed in
anything I believed and I said you know
what bro I'm not doing it for honest
as a matter of fact I'm not doing sag
low budgets no more
that's it I'm not doing them I deserve
to be in that other movie I deserve to
be in two categories up and within two
[__] months and I probably said no to
three or four more long day movies and
within two months I got a call on a
Friday that I was going in for a
Sylvester Stallone movie and the movie
was [__] Grudge Match
listen I didn't get an Academy Award for
that nobody saw that movie Kevin Hart
dinero whatever
but by me holding out look what I did
get
that's the mindset
it's little things like that it's not
[__] whining
not whining about what everybody else
has and not worrying about it wouldn't
you and it's very hard to say like
you're like Joey I know when I first got
to La 97 to 99 I I'm not gonna lie I got
upset when somebody would get somebody
that dude just followed me he couldn't
even [__] do a joke you know that and
they're getting more stuff than you are
and you walk around angry and then one
day you go you know what I do a lot
better focusing on me than what I would
do on focusing on him or him
and once you start focusing on him or
them boom there you [__] go because
your focus is on you so don't focus on
whatever cars Tom is buying or what
watch he talks about or what helicopter
he takes to Joe Rogan these guys
sacrifice tons
think of your life if you couldn't go to
a wedding on a Saturday
and as a matter of fact you don't want
to go to a wedding you're on a [__]
roll next time you get mad at Tom or Joe
Rogan or any of these guys for having
stuff that you wish you had or you
wanted don't get mad at them get mad and
go this is what I need to do to get
those things to have those [__]
things you know resolutions are [__]
coming what do you think I'm not banging
my head for what resolutions I want to
do I want to read more I want to read
two books a month I want to lose [__]
weight you know I want to figure out
what I want to do with my life at
[__] 60. you know what I want to do
with my life at 60. so
it's uh it's [__] rough guys but
don't blame your [__] what you're not
doing on the world
the bluebird of happiness is not going
to [__] help you uh you know all
these people that we expect to [__]
help us in our life are not going to
help you it's all put on you for years I
walked around frustrated in Hollywood
frustrated nobody's helping me nobody's
doing this when did I start rocking and
rolling when I took matters into my own
hands when I started getting breakdowns
and making my own [__] videotapes
hiring a guy do you think I had 50 bucks
to hire a guy to do a [__] audition
tape for you no but you want it you'll
figure out I won't snort coke that night
Joey how about that don't snort coke and
shoot the [__] audition video once I
started taking it into my own Realms
into my own hands I started [__]
doing things
you know I I wanted my career to expand
did I [__] sit there did I write
better jokes no I wrote better jokes but
I became a Storyteller I'm a natural
Storyteller what was that going against
it and I know when I did the podcast I
told stories I told stories of my life
to let you [__] know that this wasn't
no Cakewalk there that yeah nobody just
gives you [__] and yeah some people
having a better Journey than others I
had a rough journey and I tell you what
I enjoyed every moment along the way
from eating the [__] 2000 Edibles to
[__] you know sleeping in a bus to go
on the road diesel it's all part of the
gig but jealousy insecurity is not so if
you want to go on a [__] better gig
in 2023
this is the way to do it right your
[__] goals Journal don't be jealous
of other people be [__] happy for
other people
and look at it this way that's what I
started doing don't take a hold of
against me but just go like this if that
[__] idiot
could do that
think about what the [__] you could do
you call that guy an idiot all the time
man when you talk to your wife you're
like that my [__] brother-in-law is a
[__] since he's such a [__] idiot
right that's what I always did if that
guy is such a [__] idiot and he got
eight million dollars for shining shoes
what can you [__] do with your life
that's how I look at and it's helped me
a thousand [__] percent better so
I don't know it's a Monday morning
motivation [__] it's December
19th we got 11 days maybe 12 days left
in this [__] and then we have a
second chance of
not being insecure we have a second
chance of not having to sleep in a
basement on a mattress with a sheet you
know why because you're a [__]
American and that's what that means God
didn't make you get born in [__]
Africa with flies on you or you know and
uh whatever the [__] sand on Easterville
so you could walk up to the border and
have it put you on a bus to New York and
[__] like that you know God gave you a
great opportunity why do you ever think
about that like I could have been born
and [__] Yugoslavia I'd be getting
hit with a missile right now from the
[__] ukrainians or whatever oh how
come I wasn't born in Ukraine right now
and I'm [__] you know carrying some
dead teacher to the hospital whatever
the [__] they're doing over there now
think about it and think about if you
really want to I think I'm gonna go see
Rainbow next week with with Cheap Trick
and then you wonder why nothing's
happening for you this these are all the
things guys get up in the morning look
at that [__] flag and go somebody
is sucking my dick today I'm getting
tired of living this way I mean I did it
you get tired of living in a [__] one
bedroom with nine [__] cats you know
I got sick and [__] tired of it and I
couldn't keep putting it on my wife I
couldn't keep putting it on well the the
scripts aren't coming in fast enough
well that means you gotta double the
[__] up [__] sucker and get the [__]
out there
I love you [__] with all my
heart don't forget laughing gas is in
New Jersey now
Stoners Club [__] use code Uncle
Joey for 10 off Lifetime and don't
forget tonight we got a great Monday
night [__] football line you got
Green Bay against uh the Rams in Green
Bay
[__] my man needs to win and that's
it and I said I ain't got nothing else
for you [__] we're gonna be
here again on Thursday and I don't know
what we're doing for the holidays we
might just shut this [__] down
and leave this on your own and try to
come up with a new [__] scam for
2023. beside that I love you
[__] with all my heart thank
you for watching today I hope I didn't
offend nobody with this podcast but it's
true you know stop [__] looking at
that guy like he's somewhere somebody
better than you they all put their pants
on one leg at a time if Tom could do it
you could [__] do it if I could do it
you could [__] me do it I'm a real
[__] [__] I love you stay black
have a great holiday week and now for a
word for my [__] sponsor Jack
all right I want to thank you
[__] for listening today don't
forget if you're stuck things aren't
going your way lately and you want to
talk to somebody it's better help if
life came with a user manual things
would be easy for everybody but it
doesn't so navigating the career change
a relationship becoming apparent listen
that takes you into uncertainty and
that's what anxiety and other things
start to pop up therapists are trained
to help you learn productive coping
skills which makes therapy the closest
thing you'll get through a user manual I
love it I didn't know where to turn I
don't like therapy often you know
whatever
but uh when I moved I was going through
some things I contacted better help and
Dana helped me out better help is online
therapy that off his video phone and
chat therapy sessions or you could
choose not to talk to anybody as the
world's largest therapy service better
help has matched three million people
were professionally licensed and better
therapist available 100 online plus it's
affordable just fill out a brief
question add a match with a therapist if
things aren't clicking and you can
easily switch to a new therapist so it
starts with you life could be simpler no
waiting rooms no traffic learn more and
save 10 off your first month with
betterhealth.com Diaz again that's
betterhelp.com Diaz the joint is also
brought to you by DraftKings NBA season
is upon us and you're [__] around
let's get the party started especially
Maryland I want to welcome you to the
draft King's world you got nowhere else
to go [__] it's crab cakes Uncle
Joey and DraftKings but tonight you've
got a tremendous NFL game and DraftKings
is the official sports betting partner
of the NFL so let's get it started you
got Green Bay given seven to the Rams
there's a trick there there's some
there's some over and under totals
tonight plus you got NBA action new
customers bet five dollars pre-game
money line on any NBA team to win that
game and you get 115 free bets when they
do download the app now to get on the
holiday hoop Bo and NFL action in
college basketball action sign up with
Coach Joey plays a five dollar pregame
moneyline bet on any NBA team to win and
get 150 in free bets if they do only at
DraftKings Sportsbook with code Joey
j-o-e-y minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details download the DraftKings
Sportsbook at enter code Joey and let's
[__] light the board on fire today
all right
I want to thank better help I want to
thank DraftKings but I also want to
thank you [__] animals you know I
love you stay black and I'll see you
when Thursday the 22nd Tip Top Magoo
laughs
foreign